ah boba fett
probably the most iconic and most feared
bounty hunter in the star wars franchise
star wars friends from across the world
would know him from his mandalorian
armor his deadly weapons and his silent
demeanor with that being said this takes
the cake for every star wars fan or
collector what's up everybody zeki here
from geek culture and today we will be
unboxing and giving our first
impressions of the hasbro black series
boba fett helmet holy [ __ ] am i excited
for this so
roll the thing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now there's a lot of hasbro black series
helmets in the line some of you have
probably seen the darth vader black
series helmet the incinerator
stormtrooper helmet briefly seen in
chapter 8 of the mandalorian and of
course luke skywalker's x-wing pilot
helmet and boy are these super duper
heavy duty hardcore plastic i mean these
things are hefty and the black series
boba fett helmet is no different the
guys over at hasbro has put immense
effort in designing this with actual 3d
scans of the original joe johnston
helmet that was used in the empire
strikes back we are talking about the
original helmet that's actually locked
in the lucasfilm archives that has been
inset of the empire strikes back 40
years ago so
we're talking about that's some
archaeological level [ __ ] going on not
only did they manage to replicate the
external details to the highest screen
accuracy but hasbro has also managed to
add in details and elements into the
interior that you probably have never
seen before so with that being said
let's head over to the nitty gritty
details
right off the bat this looks like a
water world war 2 helmet i mean this
thing
feels or at least looks like you know
it's made out of metal but honestly it's
just hard plastic weighing about 1.5
kilograms or about 3 pounds the helmet
is painted with its iconic light olive
green color over the dome and lower
cheeks
the mandibles headband and key slot area
are accented with a dark red almost
burgundy color the upper cheeks appear
dark gray in color with the overall look
of the helmet being weathered and battle
worn in front of the helmet above the
headband are two turn signal details
that are embossed onto the helmet itself
and of course the full one piece smoke
grey tinted t-visor we all know and love
it's also good to know that when you
wear the helmet your facial features are
actually not visible so i think for me
that's like a real good plus
on the right side of the dome you can
see that there's 14 kill stripes painted
yellow and transitioning from yellow to
orange
also one of the coolest feature is the
dent on the boba fett's helmet which was
caused by darth vader deflecting boba's
blaster fire and it bounced right back
into fetz's face
i mean
here right right here the dent yeah not
only that on the left brown there's a
distinctive cat scratch
hopping over to the upper right ear is
the flippable rangefinder the stock is
metallic looking and the topper is black
with a translucent lower piece with a
black framed viewfinder the rangefinder
piece is detachable or attachable and
requires a single aaa battery to operate
the alternating flashing two red lights
and the illuminated viewfinder last but
not least is the diagnostic port which
is a nice touch though i would call it a
beauty mode
hey ladies
moving on to the interior of the helmet
hasbro has added some molded circuitry
you know like speakers and other
thingamajigs
that make it feel like an actual
mandalorian helmet
there's also a dark tan faux leather
padding which is also a nice touch
though it doesn't really do much in
terms of comfort the interior headband
is adjustable and you can actually see
the dent from inside as well so overall
i think it's pretty accurate in terms of
detail wearing the helmet on the other
hand
well
i mean don't expect it to be comfortable
or ergonomic in that sense i mean after
all this is a collectible i mean it's
science fiction it's star wars right so
you can't expect costumes and uniforms
to be that comfortable or functional by
definition the fact that everyone's head
size is different
so it kind of varies and you know mine
is big
and you know what else is big
my brain of course you sick
another thing that you might experience
wearing the helmet is that you can't
really see the rangefinder through the
visor's point of view no it doesn't
align with your right eye so you know
technically when you flip this it's
it's kind of in your peripheral vision
it's not really
you know you can't aim things with that
so like i mentioned before some things
are just meant for aesthetics and you
know don't be too
and don't be too heavy said about not
being it fully functional or at least
100 functional so the verdict it's great
i actually love it
and i'm sure role players and cosplayers
will be excited on one too though of
course i wish there could have been more
to be added in terms of function like
perhaps a voice modulator
or even some voice line from the bounty
hunter himself well yeah okay fine i
mean he only had like what four lines in
the movie but
still still
but i digress this is probably one of
the most detailed mass produced helmets
ever
and if you're planning to get one it's
already available now so yeah go get it
really get one please get one and get
one for me too this is not mine get one
for me
so we hope you guys enjoyed the video
for more stunning details and pictures
head over to the link in our description
below like share this video and don't
forget to subscribe if you already
haven't and don't forget to smash that
notification bell icon so you can stay
updated to our latest news and videos
also leave a comment down below tell us
do you like my helmet do you hate it do
you want to get one what do you think
hasbro could have done better until then
see you on the next one